[Music]
this is Nick bouquet
even if his face doesn't look familiar
to you the faces underneath the brims of
his expertly crafted hats definitely
will Nick and his team send out around
6,000 hats a year from their Venice
Beach shop while the hats have become
regulars and fashion magazines and at
red-carpet events they're also made for
people who just really appreciate a good
hat and who are willing to pay up to
$1,000 for one so what exactly goes into
making a luxury hat and what puts the
price tag in the realm of designer bags
or heels making is is a secret trade and
a craft that either gets passed down
from generation to generation
or you can apprentice under somebody but
generally it's such a secretive trade
and and something that that's so
personal that most people don't really
reveal the secret so it's only through
trial and error lucky for us it gave us
an inside look at the process his
namesake brand has honed in on refined
over years of experimentation the
process is so detailed that by the time
it's over what's left is not just a hat
but a wearable piece of art if he had a
signature it'd be these fur felt
masterpieces the process will vary among
clients and desired outcomes but
generally each new hat starts with a
healthy dose of steam
steaming the fabric makes it pliable so
that Nick can shape it into the basic
body of the Hat which he does by
stretching it over a wooden block he
uses an iron to flatten down the brim of
the Hat once in shape it dries for up to
24 hours after drying the felt is smooth
with a sander the brim is trimmed to the
requested width and sanded once again a
logo branded sweatband gets sewn into
the base of the brim which will help the
Hat keep its shape by this stage Nick's
hats are smooth and perfectly shaped
which makes it all the more interesting
when he decides to set one of those hats
on fire fire has been a technique in hat
making that's been around since really
the beginning to sort of burn off the
extra fibers that are on the hot we just
took it a step or two further and
letting it you know sort of magically
patina in its own way with the products
that we use it comes out with this
really unique sort of aged style much
like what jeans have done in the last
10-15 years with a bit of like washing
and distressing to give it that that
already worn in look and I think a lot
of my clients and a lot of people really
you know really love the idea of
something that is new but feels vintage
it's really hard to quantify how long it
takes a hot there's so many processes
involved but generally we like to really
sort of take our time and and make sure
that you know every component is is done
right so it could be anywhere from three
four days to a week to really make a hot
perfect but what exactly makes these
hats cost so much first of all the price
of fur Pelt is extremely expensive we
pride ourselves in getting the best
material possible and then on
top of the cost of the fur felt and the
leathers and everything that gets
involved in the packaging is is really
expensive because we do it at the utmost
quality it's also the craftsmanship that
we've learned and that we perfected over
the years in this in this unique style
that that we've adopted and made that is
what is niku cane that stands out
besides all the other Ren Nick's hats
have stood out enough for his brand to
become Hollywood's go-to forehead wear
but this celebrity designer status
wasn't exactly what he was aiming for
I started making hats purely by chance
by accident I think a lot of the times
people would ask me like are you the Mad
Hatter either matters by the nature of
what my design was and I always say yeah
you got to be I am the Mad Hatter
because you got to be really crazy to
want to start a hat business and it's
been really challenging but you know it
all spawned from from passion and I
think that's like what is the most
important thing and what keeps me going
I love what I do and I'm so passionate
about it
[Music]
you